[Música]
[Aplausos]
nuestra percepción determina nuestra
realidad lo que observamos
y así capa a capa vamos construyendo una
imagen con la que configuramos el mundo
y a partir
de la que reaccionamos y vemos cómo esto
se conecta con lo que es la creatividad
la creatividad es como una pértiga que
nos lanza hacia arriba y nos permite
alcanzar nuevas nuevas perspectivas ver
el mundo desde otro sitio
la creatividad es un motor funciona con
una energía universal y renovable las
ganas de saber la curiosidad
y en ese proceso como diseñador os
quiero invitar a conocer algunos
proyectos algunas aplicaciones prácticas
con la curiosidad como hilo conductor
como aterrizamos una idea en la realidad
es cómo resolvemos un problema pero a
veces ese aterrizaje en la realidad es
forzoso y es cuando aparece el fracaso y
el fracaso el bendito fracaso es clave
para el desarrollo acertado y talentoso
de la creatividad
hace unos meses mi hija noa comenzó a
perseguir su sombra tendríais que ver su
cara lo intentaba una y otra vez y igual
que le pasa a mi hija en mi profesión la
investigación es la sombra que siempre
está por delante la que te lleva a
buscar el porqué de algo y el buscar
soluciones
vivimos en un mundo con una cantidad de
problemas producto del modelo de consumo
que nos afectan a todos como recursos
limitados residuos contaminantes
personas excluidas alertas climáticas y
el hecho de que nos afecte a todos
obliga a que el diseño también se
posicione en este caso es el ecodiseño
el ecodiseño es el diseño sostenible
me gusta verlo como una historia de amor
entre la ingeniería y la sensibilidad
ambiental
el como aterrizas esa idea en la
realidad y como aplicas criterios de
ecodiseño se traduce en como minimizar
el impacto ambiental
cuando tienes que pasar de un esbozo a
la realidad es cuando tienes que
parametrizar y poner en variables
físicas lo que al principio era sólo una
idea en este primer ejemplo que os
muestro me invitaron a dividir el
auditorio de un museo y permitir
múltiples usos
lo resolví con un sistema de paredes
móviles con ruedas
estas paredes curvas están formadas por
diferentes módulos y una de sus
peculiaridades es que la estructura
vertical está apoyada en unas lamas que
permiten cambiar la opacidad de las
paredes esto se traduce en que estas
paredes permiten según la posición de
las lamas que se vea a través de ellas
una pared que permite ver a través de
ella pero aparte de la cuestión formal
que puede llamar la atención a mí lo que
me preocupaba era por la cuestión del
ecodiseño intentar resolver este
problema con el mínimo de consumo
energético y de materiales para ello
después de muchas maquetas y tecnología
de corte mecanizado resolvimos el puzzle
con sólo cinco tipos de piezas y es que
la tecnología te ayuda en este caso
tecnología de corte mecanizado un
sistema sus tractivo por el que desde un
bloque de material va sacando únicamente
lo que necesitas por eso era crucial que
fuesen sólo cinco tipos de piezas
la tecnología como os decía puede ser
una ayuda como la impresión aditiva 3d
una tecnología deslumbrante que está
revolucionando el mundo a nivel de
producción local porque precisamente
permite deslocalizar la producción la
tecnología de impresión aditiva 3d
funciona fundiendo un material que capa
a capa y formando volúmenes cuerpos
estos cuerpos volumétricos pueden ser
cualquier cosa desde un prototipo hasta
una prótesis hasta un juguete hasta una
pieza necesaria para una cuestión
biomédica es decir que el el campo de
posibilidades es enorme pero una de las
cosas que me atrajo dentro de la idea
del ecodiseño de la impresión 3d es la
posibilidad de usar una materia prima de
origen renovable a través de unos
bioplásticos que se obtienen de cultivos
de maíz y de remolacha
y además fácilmente biodegradables
entonces la tecnología te puede ayudar y
si además te puede ayudar además con una
materia prima sostenible mucho mejor y
aquí no todo iba a ser tan bonito es
donde entra el fracaso porque tenemos
muchas herramientas tenemos muchos
recursos pero el fracaso es un elemento
esta piedra en el camino que siempre
aparece
y realmente el fracaso es uno de los
puntos clave de lo que os quiero exponer
recuerdo como precisamente a través de
un proceso bastante cansado de cerca de
un año
fracasé rotundamente en un proyecto de
visualización de datos intentaba buscar
una relación entre la actividad humana y
el impacto ambiental el proyecto podría
hacerse el problema fue una cuestión de
datos al no poder precisar con exactitud
una cosa con la otra
tuvimos que abandonar el proyecto y en
ese patinazo aprendimos algo
en una de las pruebas que estábamos
haciendo con mi hermano álex
desarrollamos una maqueta de la isla
impresa en 3-d
no buscábamos en realidad nada con eso
fue como una parte fallida del proyecto
pero aquella maqueta lo cambió todo
aquella maqueta nos permitió que a
partir de un error de un fracaso
apareciese una solución a un problema la
cuestión es que a través de esta maqueta
recuerdo que la miraba con los ojos
cerrados
empecé a pensar en la mirada en lo que
nos provoca en como la mirada es una
puerta de entrada a la realidad pero a
la vez es una puerta que no es única
porque no todos vemos el mundo de la
misma manera y a raíz de estar palpando
aquella maqueta con los ojos cerrados
pensé en que si nosotros fuésemos ciegos
nuestra realidad sería muy diferente por
tanto os pido que hagáis un ejercicio de
imaginación y que intentéis pensar cómo
sería vuestra vida si fueseis personas
invidentes cómo afectaría esto a
vuestras relaciones a vuestra situación
laboral a vuestra experiencia del arte a
vuestro cotidiano
es imposible imaginar algo así porque
vivimos atados a nuestros sentidos
entonces dentro de esa casuística
atrapados en nuestros sentidos vemos qué
cambia mucho y por tanto esta percepción
qué determina nuestra realidad es la que
marca cómo experimentamos el mundo
pensad una cosa en el mundo 4 de cada
100 personas sufren algún tipo de
discapacidad visual y en su grado más
extremo 50 millones
la ceguera absoluta
por tanto los receptores sensitivos que
en nosotros captan formas y colores en
las personas ciegas no cumplen esta
función y la discapacidad la aparente
discapacidad en realidad es una alta
capacidad de otros sentidos en este caso
táctil entonces a partir de aquella
máquina empecé a pensar que podíamos
hacer algo al respecto
allí continuando con la investigación
descubrí cosas sorprendentes como que
por ejemplo solamente una de cada diez
personas invidentes conoce el código de
lectoescritura braille entonces esto les
provoca un montón de problemas a la hora
de su inserción sociolaboral a su hora
de mejorar su situación de vida y empecé
a pensar cuál era el motivo y al final
uno de los motivos prevalentes es que
los diseñadores la mayoría de
diseñadores no son ciegos
y ahí precisamente es donde
al no traducirse lo que se ve a lo que
se toca falta algo
por tanto busque cómo hacer más con
menos y de aquel error de aquel fracaso
de aquel proyecto que no funcionó
salió indirectamente otro qué tiene que
ver con esto tiene que ver en traducir a
objetos las cosas las cosas ya son
objetos pero buscar indagar acerca de
cómo ver con el tacto ese proyecto se
llama la mano lectora un proyecto para
facilitar el aprendizaje temprano de
lectoescritura braille por tanto unir
los puntos impresión 3 de niños
invidentes a los que les cuesta aprender
braille y así nació el proyecto que os
comento y un ejército de objetos donde
básicamente podemos ver que hay cuerpos
volumétricos con una codificación en
braille asociada a la inicial del objeto
que representan en este proyecto me
ayudan un panel internacional de
expertos en didáctica braille y gracias
a ellos estamos perfeccionando el la
herramienta es una
para adquisición temprana de la
asociación braille
por tanto el hecho de traducir objetos
algo tridimensional nos permite que los
niños aprendan antes porque justamente
se estimula su sensibilidad y porque su
capacidad de asombro está continuamente
incentivado sensibilidad asombro y
cuando trabajamos en esa línea aparecen
cosas fantásticas como esa adquisición
temprana el proyecto tiene muchas
posibilidades y las estamos explorando
como por ejemplo pasar cuadros objetos
de arte y objetos volumétricos fotos
objetos volumétricos las posibilidades
realmente son bastante interesantes
también estamos explorando la conexión
con museística para que los museos sean
realmente accesibles y buscando una
traducción completa de todo el
patrimonio que haya expuesto a objetos
que se puedan palpar ya está en algunos
museos y algunos museos ya se han
interesado en las virtudes de este
proyecto pero en realidad las
posibilidades del concepto son más
grandes permiten por ejemplo desarrollar
el concepto de turismo accesible
imaginaos un mirador donde la persona
invidente pudiese palpar un territorio
que tiene delante nosotros lo vemos
ella lo recorrería tácticamente
prácticamente gracias a su habilidad
en realidad las posibilidades son
bastante prometedoras y en este camino
en el camino de híbridas una necesidad
social con impresión 3d he conocido a
diseñadores muy interesantes como
guillermo que aplica su talento para
fabricar prótesis para personas
mutiladas un trabajo realmente
espectacular
y es que cuando la sensibilidad y la
creatividad se unen aparece con mucha
fuerza y con generosidad algo más grande
de lo que había empezado
y por supuesto vuelve el fracaso porque
no todos los proyectos se desarrollan
así como imaginamos sino que en
ocasiones surge algo que no te esperabas
y en este caso después de miles de horas
de impresión desarrollando los
prototipos de la mano lectora vi que
aquella solución me había provocado un
nuevo problema y son residuos porque la
impresión 3d no es perfecta y produce
residuos y vivimos en un mundo
ciertamente imperfecto y estos residuos
aunque estén hechos de un filamento
biodegradable resulta que el sistema de
gestión de residuos no lo procesa y por
tanto se incinera se dan estas
situaciones entonces desde la filosofía
del ecodiseño me parecía una aberración
que solucionando un problema generación
un otro otro problema más grande
estos residuos provienen de las pruebas
fallidas provienen de los soportes de
las piezas que se imprimen porque es una
impresión aditiva capa a capa como si
tuviésemos una manga de pastelero y
vamos capa a capa creando un objeto los
voladizos son los que requieren estos
soportes y estos soportes son los que
después son un residuo así que le empecé
a dar vueltas a cómo hacer más con menos
y cómo revalorizar un residuo asignación
nuevo proyecto filamentos reciclados
filamentos reciclados para impresión 3d
es un sistema por el que por el mismo
proceso tecnológico de la impresión 3d
pero cambiando la dirección
lo que obtenemos son filamentos
trituramos el residuo lo calentamos y lo
excluimos nuevamente para hacer
filamento para continuar imprimiendo de
este modo cerramos el círculo
multiplicamos por 10 el factor de vida
del polímero que es la base del
filamento y además le introducimos bajo
la idea de la economía circular un
residuo en el sistema productivo
optimizamos ecodiseño y gracias a este
proyecto hemos visto que los materiales
sostenibles son un paso es decir que en
todo el problema que resuelve el
ecodiseño que intenta resolver es una
parte por eso hemos invitado a centros
educativos a que se sumen a este
proyecto y nos cedan esos residuos ya
tenemos 16 centros interesados con eso
se ha creado una red de reciclaje de
bioplásticos igual que pasó hace unos
años con el papel reciclado también lo
podemos hacer con los plásticos ya es
posible
ahora las escuelas y empresas que no
usen impresión 3d todavía ya tienen una
excusa social y ambientalmente
responsable para sumarse a esta
revolución
y recapitulando vemos qué
el fracaso y el éxito en realidad no son
nada son meramente partes del camino y
en este proceso nos enseñan cómo
esquivar una problemática y cómo superar
una visión que antes nos tenía
precisamente atrancados y sin aparente
salida
se puede hacer es decir pensar en cómo
la cantidad de problemas que antes
mencionábamos recursos limitados
sentidos limitados
todos tenemos sentidos limitados en
algún aspecto un sistema productivo con
una visión limitada
eso como lo compensamos precisamente con
la creatividad y la tenacidad gracias a
esto estos elementos podemos transformar
esos problemas en soluciones
y bueno al final depende únicamente de
nosotros decidir si queremos ser
meramente pasajeros o tripulantes
activos de toda esta problemática porque
pensad que esto nos afecta a todos en
esta nave viajamos todos
el camino creativo siempre nos ayudará
contacto sensibilidad
y os animo a recorrerlo
[Aplausos]
ah